hello everyone and welcome to another
most incredible game uh from the 23rd
european team championship it's from the
final round and they're uh battling it
out for first place anton corbel of
ukraine versus gabriel sergion of um
armenia and it's uh well it's it's a
beautiful game you guys will enjoy it
and you will want to show it to everyone
uh it's a very short and well for for
good reason as you might have imagined
from the thumbnail maybe some of you
haven't but you know some of you might
have uh and we've mostly been covering
alireza during this uh entire uh
tournament as he had this incredible run
he won over 30 uh elo rating points in
one month
and uh he got that second place in the
uh world uh feed a ranking uh just below
magnus carlsen and of course he also
broke the 2800 barrier making him the
youngest ever player to to achieve such
a thing so we've uh uh you know
overlooked the actual champions of the
uh european team championship that is
team ukraine and this is uh one of the
games that i decided to show so let's
check it out anton corvo with the white
pieces opens with d4 uh we have knight
to f6 c for e6 knight to c3 and sergian
goes for the nimso indian defense with
bishop to b4 and this is usually met
with queen to c2 the classical line or
e3 the traditional line um
kodobov goes for queen to c2 even though
e3 is a little bit more popular still
but
you know
both moves have their merits so here we
have castles uh and the now knight to f3
and here d5 we strike in the center and
we're fighting for the e4 square so
we're pinning the knight so the knight
is not isn't really covering d4 square
we're controlling the e4 square with the
pawn with the knight we want to play b6
bishop to b7 control the e4 square even
further so it's kind of a battle for the
four square white plays a3 he wants the
black bishop either to move or to
capture the knight on c3 and black gives
up the bishop pair here but he will win
uh some central control uh and the white
captures with the queen that's the
ups one of the upsides of playing this
variation you will not have to mess up
your pawn structure by playing b
captures in c3 we have d captures and c
for queen captures and only now b6 now
the bishop can go into the game via
bishop to b7 but also bishop to a6 might
be an idea so here bishop to g5 pinning
the knight and now bishop to b7 and now
comes rook to d1 still postponing um
castling uh
you still have to play e3 bishop
somewhere in the castle but it's uh with
a good plan because black will not be
able to execute the c5 maneuver right
away because you can just capture and
his queen will be attacked so here
knight b to d7
further preparing c5 and e3 now we have
h6 challenging the bishop here and
bishop now moves back bishop to h4 and
now there is a game where uh
c where c5 was played or no rather there
is a game where bishop to d5 was played
uh just chasing away the queen from this
active c4 square but here we have rook
to c8 and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game uh but i
would like to mention that c5 is still
possible here in combination with bishop
to d5 because after white captures you
can play bishop to d5 and now you don't
have to worry about this rook being on
the same file with the queen once the
queen moves next we're going to capture
on c5 and we're very happy here but okay
in the game sergician decided to go rook
to c8 and now we have knight to e5 so
how do you continue here white still not
uh you know rushing to the castle he
uh he's offering now
uh the black to capture this the night
but you you can't really do this if the
knight is captured yes you can double
the pawns but the knight is attacked the
queen is attacked so there's really
nothing you can do you can't block this
because the knight can't really move so
you know it's a it's a pretty bad
position for
uh for black uh so what you could do
here is after knight to e5 you could
play c5 uh but then we go into this
knight captures on these seven queen
captures on d7 and the bishop captures
an f6 busting open the king side and
after pawn captures uh probably d5 and
now after something like captures queen
to f4 white is down upon but he messed a
black spawn structure in front of the
king and he will try to get his pieces
into the attack maybe some bishop to d3
followed by maybe h4 rookie sweet rook
to g3 there are some attacking ideas
here so probably what anton corbel had
in mind if
a move like c5 was played but in the
game sergio and played g5 he said all
right let's nullify this pin altogether
and then we're not going to have any
problems and while this is true
you uh do weaken your king side somewhat
so uh we have bishop back to g3 and now
only now c5 so striking in the center
black is very much interested in opening
the center uh since quarterback's king
is still on e1 so here knight captures
on d7 queen captures and d captures on
c5 and here we reach our first pause the
video moment of the game
it's a really tense position so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for black
here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh figuring out
that you have to part with your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course queen
captures on d1 that's the absolute best
move here for black uh point is that
after king captures on d1 which is the
only move we're going to play rook f to
d8 to check and now where do you put the
king of course you have to go back king
to e1 and now we play rook captures on
c5 and white has to give back the queen
if white doesn't do this let's say white
play something like queen to b3 then
rook the c1 check for example king e2
and knight the e4 and that's a game over
there is no defense against rook to d2
it's just uh you know
nothing white plays that really really
matters here so you would have to give
back the queen and then the game
continues however after this d captures
on c five queen characters on d1 wasn't
played uh rather queen to c6 was played
but now it's going to get a little bit
easier now quarterback plays a bishop to
e5 he still doesn't allow black to just
recapture on c5 first he has to tend to
deny the knight here is hanging so
knight back to d7 and now we have bishop
back to c3 so again you can't really
play queen captures because uh well uh
it just wouldn't be all that impressive
if queen captures then uh we we can
simply capture this knight on d7 uh it's
a very very you know ugly position for
black to face because now if queen
captures bishop captures yes you can
capture the bishop but then white also
captures the bishop on b7 and you are up
a full bishop so instead after bishop to
c3 knight captures and c5 was played and
now how do you continue here with white
well we're gonna play f3 we're gonna
completely block this queen bishop
battery so we don't have to worry about
such things anymore now we're gonna
develop the bishop and hopefully castle
and there are a couple of ways black can
continue playing this you know black and
continue with something like maybe h5
maybe he can be the one that starts
pushing he can play queen to c7 there
are some uh uh other interesting moves
you can play queen back to e8 uh to open
up this rook uh
towards the queen but in the game queen
the a4 was played it's the move uh from
the thumbnail but this uh just loses the
game for black on the spot and it's
really incredible because this is uh
i mean it it's still so very early on in
the game and it's uh it's hard to
imagine that an offering of a queen
trade can blunder the game like this
it's just incredible so feel free to
pause the video and try to find why this
is so while i give you a couple of
seconds you have to see not one but two
moves at least
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing what a
monster this bishop is and that this
bishop will be the actual star of the
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show of course we trade
queens queen captures on a4 knight
captures and now uh the star moved
bishop to f6 this is just uh beautiful
and now uh you can see that um
what's what's the problem here why is
black's position so bad well uh the
bishop controls these two squares we're
gonna play h4 we're going to open up the
h file and hopefully deliver rook to h8
checkmate and the position is uh well it
simply doesn't allow black to do
anything about this i'm going to show
you what happens if black plays the
absolute best uh defense here uh which
was not played in the game but let's say
black played this let's say h5 uh
there's a reason you have to play this
now we're going to play bishop to b5
we're going to attack the knight here
that's undefended let's say bishop to c6
defends the knight and now we're going
to play bishop to a6 we attacked the
rook and once the rook moves now we play
b4 and now what do you play here
it doesn't really matter there aren't
all that many good moves here for black
for example you play bishop to b7 we're
going to play bishop to e5 and now after
the rook is attacked there's no square
for this rook you either move and
lose the bishop here uh or you know you
can't really go rook to e7 then move
like a bishop
to d6 comes so you would have to capture
here and then bishop captures on c7 uh
white wins the exchange black has no
compensation for the exchange and it's a
winning position for white so this is
with absolute best the defense uh you
know that's
yeah also completely losing so no no
point in playing this sergician tried
rook to c2
but it doesn't help all that much here
kobo just strikes with h4 of course he
wants to capture captures and then rook
to h8 checkmate so black played the g4
of course he wants to keep the h file
closed but now comes rook to d4 and he
was in this position on move 23 that
gabriel sergio resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
incredible incredible game only 23 moves
uh and you know it never amazes me
how how the how the names of indian can
always surprise us like this uh you know
uh sometimes by winning sometimes by
losing but here uh the game ended even
though if the game had continued the
game would be uh you know just as
beautiful so i'm gonna show you what
would happen if the game continued the
problem is your knight is hanging here
and it doesn't really matter how you
tend to this for example you move the
knight now we play rook capture sanji
for with check and after king to h7 rook
to g7 with check king to h8 and now it
seems like uh yes there could be some
windmill action here but there isn't uh
you can't really connect the check with
anything ever anything but there is one
tricky move you can play and that is
king to d1 you attack the rook and you
ask what what
what are you going to do with the rook
bishop cover c4 pawn covers this bishop
covers pawn so the rook has to move all
the way to f2 and now we're going to
play rook captures on f7 with check king
to g8 we're going to deliver another
check rook the g7 check king the h8 and
now we can't really capture anything
because our bishop is hanging so we're
gonna move the bishop to d4 and now
we're threatening to pick up the bishop
with uh discovery from the bishop on d4
so black of course will stop this bishop
to d5 now we're going to pick up the
pawn so rook captures an a7 uh some more
windmill action rook king to g8 now rook
back to g7 check king to h8 and now a
move like b4 really puts black in a
you know completely terrible position
for example knight b3 uh we want to play
rook to d to check just bishop to c3 and
now whatever you play it doesn't really
matter
because there there's nothing you can
play all of your pieces are exactly
where where they need to be and if you
play something bishop to a8 we can just
play rook the g8
with a discovery here and once the king
moves the bishop to d3 look at this
mighty bishop pair
completely incredible and even if black
tries to give up the exchange we're not
interested in the exchange we're going
to play rook to g7 check king h8 now
rook g6 check again you can't block this
you have to play king h7 now rook
captures an e6 check we eliminate the
defender of the rook and next we're
going to capture this rook for free and
of course completely winning so that's
why sergio decided to resign this and
move 23 because he saw that after he
saves the night there's no escaping the
windmills
uh so yeah really really incredible play
by by quarterback and really impressive
how how such a thing can happen and it's
really important to you know after queen
to ace a4 is played to realize that uh
this bishop to f6 move is such a such a
powerful move that there is no defense
against all of the ideas that lurk in
the position
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it these are the final standings
of the uh online uh or rather of the
european team championship so ukraine
and france uh same amount of points but
with better additional criteria ukraine
clinches the first place second france
third poland then spain azerbaijan
armenia russia serbia germany
netherlands israel greece england
croatia georgia switzerland hungary
austria denmark and the czech republic
so those are the top 20 and 39 teams
competed so
there you have it uh very impressive
around and there were so many great
games here of course we we couldn't
cover all of them as you know them that
alireza for playing that well
but you know if you have any other uh
that you you really enjoyed and that are
you know enjoyable to watch do do
suggest them i i will cover them we
still have some time before the world
chess championship starts uh so yeah i
once again hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to elias and i would like to thank tom
darrell igor pedic rakshi jain and
constantin krangano for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day